j'ai fait des tas de choses dont je suis
pas fier j'ai blessé des tas de gens je
vais pas pouvoir continuer comme ça bien
longtemps je suis là aujourd'hui pour
vous parler des familles comme les
vôtres de l'autre côté de la terre qui
ont désespérément besoin de votre aide
il me suis dit je pourrais peut-être
tiré en afrique reconnaissait que ces
gens ont besoin d'être
vous êtes dans l'armé légale combat pour
la liberté
je m'appelle sam enchanté j'aurai besoin
d'un bon guide c'est une zone en guerre
si vous restez vous risquez de vous
faire tuer
c'est plus sûr de dormir ici que dans
leur maison dans pas là on n'a pas de
place ils sont trop nombreux
faut emmener tout ce qu'on veut on
viendra chercher les autres plus tard
[Musique]
j'ai besoin d'argent pour un véhicule de
l'accusé pourra me servir à sauver plus
d'enfants mal mais vous ne dites pas
dans le québec
[Musique]
l'armée rebelle a mis sa tête à prix si
j'ai dû faire quelque chose de bien
ils ont tout brûlé il ne resterait rien
c'est fini pour toi tu sais mon temps
non
attends attendre tu as vu ce que ça fait
il n'a pas besoin de plus tard combattez
le démon dans ce pays à votre manière et
laissez moi le combattre à nyon
sort